great nation will endure as it has
endured will revive and will prosper
and these united states have revived and
prospered growing through the years to the
greatest democracy in the world led by one
of its citizens chosen by its people from
the farms from the towns from the cities each
voter searched the constitutional rights of
a free people in the first moving pictures
ever to record a presidential inauguration
here is William McKinley as he becomes
the 25th President of the United States
although he was a great advocate of National
Preparedness and peace it was during his
administration that the shocking news from
Admiral Dewey of the sinking of the main in
Havana Harbor in 1897 spared the American
people to declare war on Spain and crush
her in three short months thus liberating
a fest Cuba during this campaign there rose
to prominence Theodore Roosevelt and his
famous Rough Riders he was elected to the
vice presidency in 1900 in McKinley's second
term and a few months later when McKinley was
assassinated at the pan-american exposition in
Buffalo he became the chief executive in 1904
Theodore Roosevelt was re-elected president his
Restless and modern mg enabled him to direct the
successful construction of the Panama Canal so
vital to our to ocean defense after France and
Spain abandoned the task as hopeless outstanding
and Roosevelt's administration was the great
conservation program for our national resources
huge tracts of land were set aside for national
parks which we know today as the tourist
centers of unexcelled beauty in 1908 William
Howard Taft was elected president he was not so
strenuously progressive as Rozelle however during
his administration the Postal Savings Bank was
created and Parcel Post inaugurated this was a
new departure for the government in competing
with private industry banking and Express
Woodrow Wilson's inauguration on the 4th of
March 1913 followed his election when Roosevelt
split with tabs and formed the progressive
Republican Party which was known to us all
as the bull moose party his administration faced
rumblings of war in Europe which threatened the
Peace of the borough and as the great nations
of Europe were in the death throes of battle
in 1916 he was reelected on the slogan he kept
us out of war and just five months later after
Germany had declared unrestricted submarine
warfare we were involved in the first world war
Woodrow Wilson signed the declaration of war
on Germany and war secretary Newton D Baker
Dawes the first best balance from every rank and
file Young America joins the fight for democracy
then came the glorious days of Armistice with
flags flying and bands playing the victorious army
returns to at homeland to present his Farsight at
14 points Woodrow Wilson sail for Paris the big
bore Boyd Georges Clemenceau Orlando and Woodrow
Wilson discussed the fate of that fallen foe
but at the signing of the treaty
at Versailles Woodrow Wilson
failed to achieve his dream for lasting peace
he returned home a bit early disillusioned man and
finished his term of office
broken in health and spirits
March 4th 1921 warren g harding took the
oath of office as the 29th president and
the keynote of his inaugural address
was back to normalcy after the hectic
world war days roar abyssion was
established in 1921 and as the
nation went dry the era of bootleggers
speakeasies and gangster warfare began
one of the highlights at the Harding
administration was the famous arms
conference millions of dollars of unfinished
warships were scrapped in an attempt to create
world peace warren g harding died suddenly in the
summer of 1932 in the midst of national scandal a
few hours after the news of Harding's death Calvin
Coolidge was summon from the hills of Emmaus and
fits the oath of office as president of the United
States from his father a justice of the peace
in Plymouth Barnes fostered factories home and
subsidy was given shipping by means of profitable
mail contracts and Coolidge's administration
became an era of heretofore unseen posterity
after Coolidge is famous I do not choose to
run Herbert Hoover succeeded him on March 4
1929 and by autumn of that year the Coolidge
boom market exploded the stock market crashed
and economic crisis follows unemployment
increase and the country sank to the depths
of the greatest depression in its history
and as ever the people looked to Washington
to restore order and prosperity Franklin
Delano Roosevelt was elected in 1932 and
during a wild panic of bank runs and strikes
and the very day of his inauguration those
that closed all the banks in the country
under an old statute bill and then repealed
in 1936 Roosevelt was reelected by
the largest electoral majority in
history he faced four years with many problems
neutrality national defense disastrous farming
waterpower
Social Security gold keeping the American
dollar bus undestand the borough unemployment
WPA providing for the jobless until they could be
absorbed in private industry in 1939 the shadow of
Hitler's swastika appeared on the horizon to
extinguish the light of Europe's democracies
together with his accomplice Benny - Mussolini
they threatened the freedom of the whole world
thank in the United States in the
cities mine Mills factories and
on the farm America United in the greatest
peacetime defense program in all its history
and elected Franklin Delano Roosevelt
to up third term its first third term
president and as long as the United States
of America enjoys the freedom of its great
democracies mr. president will come and
go the choice of people by the people and